back
so for the next session we're uh super
excited to have a lot he's on he's going
to be talking about a regret
minimization approach to multi-agent
control
um oh i'll just do a quick reminder so
again the last session of the day today
is going to be this like open problem
session it's going to be uh super
informal not recorded or anything so
yeah if you have uh you know open
problems you're excited about put your
name on the board
but with that i'll uh i'll let a lot
take it away cool thanks
the volume working people hear me yeah
my name is
pleasure to be here
thank you dylan for inviting me and
kostas and whoever else is in charge of
this uh seminar it's really a pleasure
to be here really a pleasure after all
this time to be able to talk to people
face to face and already like just a
couple of days so many ideas it's it's
amazing so
pleasure to be here
and this is work with the udaya guy he
was my student he's here and he's the
main author of this work
and
udari and naomi leonard was a professor
udar is her student and naomi is a
famous control theorist from princeton
um
and this work is about regret
minimization
for multi-agent control what is
multi-agent controller it's same thing
as multi-agent trail so
same topic we've been discussing
here's the motivation i always like to
think of a motivating
problem so that we don't kind of get too
up high in the air with a theory and
it's kind of grounded by something
by the way please feel free to ask me
anything during the talk uh i don't
think i will take the full 45 minutes
no one ever complains if it ends before
time so that's good
uh so we have a lot of time for
questions
uh the motivation is the following so we
have some
um device like let's this grown here
and it has actuators or the motors
four motors in this case
[Music]
and
what will be a good way to design a
robust system i mean there are many
approaches to this
thought process you can think okay i'm
going to design until various
robustness hidden in the design of the
system and so forth but the approach we
take is what if each
actuator if each motor is independent
and acting
rationally irrationally means it
minimizes regret
can that give
rise to extra robustness in the sense
that let's say one motor fails
the rest of the
motors will continue to kind of do the
best they can and maybe still fly the
drone
uh maybe there is some
noise or information difficulties maybe
we want to add the motor and we don't
want to change the whole system we add
something in in detail you know some
poor pillow and then
wanted to keep on doing well i want to
adjust so a lot of
advantages to this thought process i
guess some of them were enumerated by my
colleagues here today yesterday
of independent agents acting together
for some joint
goal
the difficulty of course is that regret
minimization in non-convex games is hard
and we just heard a talk excellent talk
by noah who said as much he didn't talk
so much about the regret but about
equilibrium
but the regret was even known before
that to be heard in this kind of
situations so it's a hard problem
hello so it's very nice to have heard a
lot of the the related work already in
this conference by eugene and noah
and others there's been a lot of work in
there so this is very recent and has
some theory to it which is great
a lot of um
work in the control literature
uh decentralized distributed control
um
our take is different okay than what you
have held it's different from several
aspects so
we heard that computing equilibrium is
hard and therefore people resulted that
my predecessors in this conference
resulted to relaxing the notion of
equilibrium
and maybe doing all sorts of um
clever algorithms to allow for it and so
on
um because it's not convex it's not the
convex setting okay so i'm gonna do
something different i want not only
equilibrium something much better i want
optimality but it's going to be with a
stronger set of assumptions
okay so that's going to be the
distinguishing
theme compared to what we've held and
it's not like it's not directly it's
related right we're both attacking the
same problem from a different direction
and i think this this kind of approach
also has merit as i hope to
convince you
yeah so our focus is stronger notion
optimality but with stronger assumptions
and before i tell you what the game
theoretic setting is i will start from a
simpler setting
this simpler setting is online convex
optimization i think well i know a lot
of you in the audience and therefore i
know that all of you know this very well
i will still give you the formal
definition and then say what is the
extension to the multi
player setting that i'm looking for and
how that will give rise to something in
the control setting
so in online context optimization we
have a player and an adversary and the
player picks some point in a convex set
which we denote by x and then the
adversary gives a
a cost function which is convex so this
is different from rl typically we have
all these weird things right transition
matrix and so on it's not convex here
it's convex
and then there is a loss and we look at
the aggregate loss
which of course nothing can be said
about because this is an adversarial
game however
um we can look at the regret which is
the difference between the total loss
and the best
loss in hindsight from any point in the
convex set
we say that we minimize regret if the
average such difference goes to zero
with the number of iterations
um and there are a lot of algorithms
known that minimize it for example
online gradient descent can move in the
direction of the
works good the direction of the gradient
of the last cost function even though it
has to not with the the future one it's
still known to minimize regret and
optimal rate of square root number of
iterations
um
i went through this very quickly if
there are any questions please ask ahead
i think all of you are familiar with it
i'm going to look at an extension of
this okay so the extension is the
following i'm looking at the distributed
oco setting we have many players each of
them potentially chooses a point
from a diff they're all the same boxes
here because i didn't have the power to
draw new ones but they could be
potentially different
uh sets okay
and then they each every iteration they
give each of them gives a a point and
then the adversary gives the cost
function which is convex in every one of
the arguments
and it's applied to
all the points simultaneously
this kind of a joint cost okay it's a
joint cost
and it's repeated again and again and
similarly to before we would like
the average regret to convert to zero
with the number of iterations
the hope here is that we can
optimize the joint cost
even though they are each acting
independently
that or minimize regret even though
they're rich acting independently
yeah
clear so this kind of thing
not exactly this thing surprisingly so
such a trivial setting i would i was
sure it was considered but not exactly
this there's some kind of similarities
that we're going to fill in the
literature as far as i know not exactly
this
there are various knowledge graphs or
whatever this knowledge everyone knows
everything there's no knowledge issue
here at all okay it's like a joint game
no question about the setting
so now
what can we do can we
can regret be minimized asynchronously
let's say that each player uses no
regret algo with them
maybe gradient descent maybe mirror
descent i don't know what
and then
we can define this the naive thing right
so each player has a loss function which
is
the loss given what all the other
players are doing
this is a convex function that's by
assumption by my construction
and let's say they each minimize regret
will it converge to
the optimum
any guess from the audience
yes
no okay that's a good guess but
good guess but i thought so too honestly
so here is an here is an
example that's kind of i was surprised
by that this is actually the only point
in my talk is this and the next slide
kind of like a small point which is neat
i think so
think of this loss function we have two
variables scalars let's say and given by
this expression
and now
consider two players that they alternate
they play minus one one one one once you
know like this
they each minimize regret because when
you
plug in minus one one and look what the
other one is doing
it's doing great you know it's kind of
like doing the best thing for that
particular
choice of the adversary
so
they actually both have a negative
regret compared to the best fixed so in
the instantaneously they're doing great
you look at the best in high side the
best in hindsight is going to be zero
because the alternate one right you see
that yeah so that kind of plus one minus
one that's gonna be zero
uh but
it's not optimal global play optimal
global play zero
so they have linear regret compared to
the optimal global plane
this is the main point that
but the yeah thing fails
because i wanted to converge to
global optimal
i thought you wanted some regret notion
yeah but for a convex function which
implies global optimality
okay so
let me spend a bit of time on it
because it cost us the asking question
i'm guessing
other people didn't see this so
yeah so i would like this global regret
will be optimized right for context
optimization this going to zero means
that the average point converts to the
best in hindsight
and
i want this to happen by a black box
reduction mainly that each player is
playing low regret by itself on its own
local function
so this is how i define the local
function this is the global function
they have negative regress is good for
them but they don't converge to the
global optimal cost
so i find this surprising i mean it's
not such a you know difficult thing to
show but it's still interesting
and the question is can you still do
something can you still
reduce from
local regret to global regress
so
what you can do is linearize so you can
put
some box here that hides what the global
cost function is
okay so this box you can still think of
the same protocol
the
adversary gives you a cost function the
players give you the the points and so
on
but in the middle i'm going to put some
linearizer that is like the game
moderator you can think of it so this is
going to sit in the helicopter there is
some joint thing going to give
distribute the cost function to the
players he's not going to give them the
residual loss like before he's going to
give them some linearized version of the
of the loss and they are going to do
whatever they want in terms of
regretting minimization it's still going
to work okay
um what is this linearization let me see
the show so this laminarization is just
going to be the local gradient at the
joint space of the
points they played
so each of them plays a point x t sub
i whatever you want to call it the k
players let's say so at time t first one
play xd1 and so on you take the gradient
one for each one one for each coordinate
and give it look at the joint gradient
and define
this
joint linear loss function okay
so the joint linear loss function
decomposes into the separate coordinates
that's that's basically the property we
need so the convexity it's not enough
convex
separability i guess if it was convex
but separate would be okay but this is
uh why would it be the case you know
but once we do this simple thing
this is the whole proof that you can
basically separate out the regrets into
the individual ones
and get the global regret guarantee use
the sum of the individual ones
okay
[Music]
good
so yeah that's a simple observation and
now how can we use it right so
everyone okay with me with the simple
point
how can we use it
and
yeah so distributed oco we can solve by
this simple trick
and how can we use this to control so to
explain how to use it to control i need
to give you a brief explanation of some
methodology that has been
recent a recent new methodology that has
been studied a lot
and basically reduces control to online
context optimization and then i'm going
to apply what i said to that methodology
and that's how the whole thing is going
to work so i'm going to now explain
control from the lens of online context
optimization and it's like a couple of
slides so bear with me
um
so here is the definition of the control
problem this is not a general
rl markov decision process because we
have much more structure in the
transition matrices so
think of this small drone
how does it behave we have a state the
velocity the position and so on
and this changes according to the system
dynamics and
of the of the drone whatever the motor
are doing this can be described by
a changing linear dynamics where it's
linearized according to the jacobian of
the dynamical function on the local
um state
u is an action is what you how much
power you give to each of the motors and
w is some kind of um
disturbance that is adversarial i guess
we had a talk here about lqr right so
that's exactly the same kind of model
i'm talking about
linear local linear dynamics they can
change so that actually allows for
nonlinear dynamics
and some cost functions that are appear
online
and this is a fairly general
formulation because it captures
linear or near-linear dynamics can
capture adversarial noise can capture
adverse arbitrary loss functions not
only quadratic but any convex function
and
yeah so this is the formulation what is
the goal the goal is to find the policy
that chooses to control you
to minimize the long-term horizon cost
that is the that is the
kind of a brief statement of the control
problem
we call it non-stochastic because this w
doesn't have to be
um
like gaussian or zero mean like in
classical optimal control
the main differentiation in classical
optimal control you have gaussian noise
like a zero mean noise if you have zero
mean noise and you know how the
physics behave you can compute an
optimal policy offline you don't need to
see anything online
but like online learning if we don't if
we don't know this noise it's uh
arbitrary you cannot do that there is
nothing to compute ahead of time it's
not going to help you some noise is
going to appear you can only say
something in hindsight
and your goal becomes minimizing regret
doesn't become to do
optimal control
um
right so online control
i defined control and online control
means that you are
sequentially choosing a control input
and
you have no choice you have to minimize
regret because you have this adversarial
noises it is defined as the sum of noise
of course
versus the sum of cost of the best
policy
in hindsight
it's also called policy regret there are
various notions of policy regret in the
literature by the way this is uh
maybe not the most standout one but
still it's regret compared to the best
policy
um so we want to compete with the best
sequence of controls that take the state
generate a just like a policy right take
a state generate a control
you want to compete with that
in this kind of general setting
and
yeah any questions so far
um
okay so
yeah great question
and the question is can you
do a bus controller
um
yes you can i mean the the literature of
control is vast robust control will
amount to a min max game solution ahead
of time it will say um
what is the best controller can choose
this is the worst case noise
right
um
we know from online learning since the
world the work of foreign and shapiro
that this is very suboptimal because
what if you plan for this worst case
then it happens to be no nose at all
you're kind of doomed you did such a
such a difficult thing whereas no noise
at all you could have done much better
right so the correct notion we studying
online learning correct i mean that's
what i think is correct is regret
because you're instance optimal like for
every noise you do the best thing for
that particular noise as opposed to
pre-computing everything and the cost is
that you cannot pre-compute nothing you
have to do it online and do it ahead of
time very good question yes costas um
[Music]
the same between the counterfactual
sequence of the one you observed
the wonderful question it is the same it
is the same
just like online learning we consider
the loss function when we compare it
we don't have the load functions
changing depending on our assets
we think of them as like the adversary
gave them now do the best compared to
them
so
yeah we think of this as nature think of
it in the foreign example
material like if i take my little
helicopter over here maybe the wind is
different or if i take it over there
like
and
there are ways to deal with it maybe
i'll mention it's kind of beyond the
scope of what i'm saying
but the analogy is going to learn not to
do something more difficult which is
counterfactual
counterfactual regret is more difficult
you're saying had i done something
different
also something different than what would
be that
you should have
and i think this is the correct balance
between the two things it's not too
difficult not too easy so
so but if it was
good like if for example
imagine what i do wt scouts yeah
and had i done something else it would
still be those yeah
can you cover that case or you have to
be coordinated
[Music]
related to robust control
the paradigm there is that you design a
controller ahead of time
and and and you built it into the system
and then it has to be robust to all
possible sort of noises so
so that's that's uh this of course does
cannot end on that
i think it's much more general i mean i
think it's stronger
you can discuss the flank you want but
you can have a full discussion here
the thing about robust control is that
you redesign something for the wall
space not from a certain class of model
and here the difference is you don't do
that you see on the slide what noises
happen and your regret is compared to
the best thing
for that
that's the difference and in online
learning it's known to be much stronger
guaranteed than pre-designing big months
so in game theory it's stronger here
yeah also performs much better if i can
confidence with experiments that's not
enough
and okay
so
all right so also for control i'm not
going to need the whole
i haven't talked foreign
and happy to give but not here so
and recently there has been progress in
this storm in the following sense
there is a relaxation of the natural
repulsions the ultimate polarization of
policies lql called the linear policy it
was discussed here it's a linear
function of the state to action
and you can relax it to be
a linear
function of the past perturbations
it's called the disturbance action
controller
it's a
more general class than linear
and the nice thing about it it's convex
so linear policies are not convex you
have a convex function applied to them
the whole thing is not convex you apply
a constant function to this
policy is convex so you can do much more
things with it
and
and using various techniques it's
possible to design gradient based
controllers that are new
and they
have this regret guarantee
um and since then there is a lot of work
i would happy to refer you to an icml
tutorial from
a year ago on this subject there's a lot
of literature
here is an example of a basic result
there is an efficient algorithm that can
minimize regret versus the class of all
linear controllers
in the presence of arbitrary loss
functions arbitrary bounded noise this
is something we cannot do efficiently
not by robust and not by optimal control
or anything because
if for a general convex function if it's
in convex
computing the best linear policy can be
very hard in hindsight
so there are computational advantages
here
and
with respect to x and u is enough
they actually banned it so yeah tower
here worked on on bandits
algorithms even balance is enough
generally i'm telling you to talk to
them
okay continue
so how can we apply oco to multi-agent
control
um
so voltage control is defined like this
you have
a similar setting to before you have a
dynamical system that changes the state
and the control maybe there is an
observation so doesn't have to be full
observation
um and we have the different
agents so it's similar to the to the
control model that we find before but
now we have multiple different agents
that are all sending their own controls
to the system and the status that comes
the joint
mess of this whole thing
together with the you know the system
the observations so just like a
multi-agent version of whatever
it's a cooperative setting i consider
the cooperative setting where we have a
single context focus that we want to
optimize we want the helicopter to fly
to the destination quickly as possible
most efficiently it's possible okay it's
not that every engine wants to do its
own thing
they will minimize their own regret but
the the objective is joint that is the
setting i'm considering
um
yeah i'm assuming that every this is
full information there are various
generalization possible i'm not going to
get into them so everyone knows
everything the actions the control the
states there is no hidden nothing
and what are we trying to do
we are trying so every agent has a
policy class we want a joint policy so
every player does its own thing in such
a way that they minimize regret compared
to the best joint policy in hindsight
that's what the generalization of
distributed oco to control that's what
it means
and and our result is that you can you
can do that you can
and
you can basically have individual
algorithms each of them is regret
minimizing with respect to its own
policy class
and what you do is you merge them
together in such a way that they
minimize regret plus a small kind of
lower order term
and the way you do it let me say how do
you do it
is
exactly like distributed oco but apply
to this kind of more general setting so
what i'm gonna do is each player will
observe its observation play the control
receive the cost function and so on the
only thing is i'm going to linearize the
loss function not take the original loss
function i'm going to linearize it at
the point that each of them played and
give that to the individual players
so i basically run on stochastic control
from each of the players
and by using
the trick i showed you and there is and
the other well known results you
basically get this
regret
uh low regret both
linear time during dynamics yeah
actually it's easy to think of linear
timing
and
there are various extensions we can do
regret for time varying dynamics
and that is useful because now we can
consider non-linear so if they are
slowly changing this capture some form
of if there are smooth dynamics you can
say something about nonlinear you need
to look at adaptive regret
and they'll
start from online learning i think talk
about it a little bit you basically look
at regret in every small interval and
you say in a local area i compete with
the best converter now if your dynamics
changing slowly
you say okay i believe there is a local
linear controller which is optimal for
that because locally it's like looks
like a stationary linear dynamics so you
have optimal local optimality that's
kind of the idea
yeah
sure
yeah
is there a little badge that you use
right
so you don't need to even the policy
departmentalization you have it's not
the only depend on the last stage it has
to go back a certain history how much
history depends on the system
controllability and stabilizability
parameters and they indicate we assume
they decay to stable dynamics otherwise
it won't do nothing so it has been decay
and then and the amount of history you
take depends on this machine
so like the matrices mi you use also
have uh
yeah can we be related to this question
what's the policy class of comparison
one of the class is called the service
action controller
it's the same
as a single one but the joint every one
of them
and this is actually a general black box
reduction you can have
each controller can have its own policy
class and they look at the the
direct sum of all of them but it's most
easiest to think about
disturbance action control from each
controller and the computer the best one
this is more general than linear
information
it's more than one
at the pulse you want to take your own
like observation history yes and the
joint action correct
all
regress
with respect to the entire policy
parameterization uh
functions so
now yeah so actually related to your
question does it only apply to you know
this uh prioritization
so actually by now there are a lot of
results in this area
and for dac policy for full information
and
some some of them from my group some by
so dylan here has a nice result in this
area
there are other policies disturbance
response for partial information
there is neural network policies
um now that we can prove stuff about in
the the neural tangent kernel regime and
so on
so there are various uh policy classes
we can now talk about and give
theoretical bounds for
and this is experimentation there is a
some kind of aircraft simula
airplane simulation
um and what what uh we will with an
overall statement i guess
they
coded it up and applied different
controllers from different actuators and
see what what happens then how does the
cost behave
um and
so the top row is when all the actuators
are intact and the bottom row is when
they're
one of them is forced to
shut off and then
the the orange line i don't know how
well you can see the colors so the
orange line is the our kind of new
method and it does better than the
when we shut off one controller it does
better as you would expect
uh compared to other policies
future direction so udaya is giving a
talk today for in the open questions so
i i will leave that to him
and thank you for your attention
awesome
uh let's see do you want to start off
with an open question or circuit just
with a question i should say
um oh no answer questions okay cool
small question are there wt's uh are
they already adopted
they could they could be adapting to
your policy just like a regret is robust
to that right so uh worst case report is
robust to the noises depending on your
algorithm
and that's all fine and just the one
thing it cannot do is change
we don't we assume it's stationary like
it cost us us if we go back and play the
different policy launches
or this and the solution
but it can be necessarily adapted to the
all right solutions maybe a related
question so
i want to understand like you saw some
graphs and i want to understand what
applications are those and relatedly
uh i could imagine settings or kind of
like the different controllers like if
it's like kind of like a
group of little drones that they have to
do something
uh uh
maybe each of them has their own
disturbances uh that they expect like
they don't share everything about the
some part i mean
maybe they can communicate like i want
to understand the types of settings you
have in mind uh
if you are in the model
right so this this particular experiment
well it's kind of a toy so this is a
it's an airplane and it has i think four
actually somewhere
yeah
so there's like four different flaps
whatever this flap that flap
and then you kind of say each one of
them has a policy to it and it's gonna
and we're gonna say obviously at some
point
we're shining off one of them the flaps
stopped walking it's actually a pretty
realistic situation
so what happens then i mean the
classical approach we're going to design
a pulse to begin with that says oh
flat not working we have a sensor since
we're going to send it to some
centralized controller and he's going to
decide now to activate the new box that
will be that the classical approach
which is working well that's why no one
flies with this front flight door
so it works very well but the idea here
is that you kind of like maybe
can do something
from a different perspective so
there is no centralized policy that you
would thought of every possible thing
that flap stuck that flap also stuck
maybe there are different positions
right you can imagine situations where
they got stuck in some bad position the
airplane is gonna start turning around
and maybe there's a plan for that
particular situation so
the hope is that you have
individual agents that give them the
what the others are doing are capable of
minimizing with work on their own that's
what they are doing in centralized
planning
so they're simpler because they're
simpler you can do a better
design but you don't have to think of
the whole complication and then they
will robustly
optimize the joint
function so this is what's happening
here so the joint function i don't know
what this function is people they are
playing position or something i feel
some kind of
stability of it i'm guessing or
something like that is it stabilized
there is something so this is like uh
it's like a linearized
lqr objective basically okay so lql
objective means you have quadratic cost
which means usually it measures distance
to the objective plus energy expenditure
and you want to optimize that so you can
of course fly very fast
but maybe you want to minimize energy
and reach the destination
so that is the the cost kind of is
optimized by the individual things even
after you removed one flap
so i guess ideas to extend this to when
it's uh even more
so i guess this is an application where
there is like uh you know basically all
of these guys work to control
[Music]
of we don't have furniture because we
have millions of players or something
then we don't know what everyone is
doing and there are many issues actually
to overcome here for once i cannot
discover the actual disturbance that
happened disturbance i can discover only
if i know what everyone is doing then i
subtract that from actually what
happened and i see the disturbance i
don't know what it is i have some very
passionate information
and a lot of challenges here and i don't
know what to do here but it's a good
open question
maybe
maybe you can do something
able to the cost needs to be able to be
computable from the partial observation
available at each step
but then you can kind of do things with
a different kind of policy but
yeah these kind of uh
multiple drones things it probably won't
fit into that
level of uh personal observation
i mean there is an extension of this
with the knocks information
so
he
worked on
[Music]
like there is a modern controller you
have the linear global solutions linear
function of state and you can there is
an extension called the experience
response control can look like
some
thought that i don't know or disturbance
but only what you observe
and you can do the same thing with that
information you get interesting results
so
i think that so we have that in paper
too
but there's so much to be studied here
that i really don't know
in the beginning of our talk you
mentioned this independent learning
structure like independent learning
dynamics
eventually in your algorithm you need to
observe let's say the drone action of
everybody and but you are of course
looking for as you mentioned looking for
a better goal which is like the team
optimal or like the global optimal
solution right so i was wondering if you
like kind of is there or do you believe
there's a trade-off between the
information you can use in the algorithm
and let's say where uh we can look for
some equilibrium notion like in the game
theoretic perspective right this is a
great question i am
and
you're asking about the tension between
the the
kind of the harder goal of optimizing
but in an easier setting versus the
kind of the weaker notion of equilibrium
but in a harder game theoretic setting
what's kind of the optimal thing here
because because if you run let's say no
we're learning or like regret
minimization right algorithms
independently usually people are hoping
for that equilibrium so yeah global
optimal may be too much to expect well
the reason we took this approach because
we love regret minimization algorithms
and regret minimization algorithms are
known for online convex optimization you
slightly deviate from it they are not
known so
um it's not even not now it's impossible
like we have impossibility results that
you cannot minimize global regret
computationally
and a lot of people have even recent
results like in this area that there are
all sorts of hardness results it's
harder than an equilibrium right so she
just talked about this yesterday it's
had an equilibrium
so
but definitely it's an interesting
question i mean one of the
and i think it's really interesting to
see what what you can do if it's
slightly non-convex there are various
notions of non-convex regret that could
be applicable here
um
what kind of solution concepts they
yield and so on i definitely think it's
interesting i think this is the probably
the most exciting
kind
of direction i see from i sense from
this workshop for now yeah
thank you very much
right very interesting uh i was thinking
so this is a little bit outside of the
box so uh let's just speculate on i was
thinking about economic applications and
uh you know the next
thing for me would be to think about
these agents trying to get to the same
objective but trying to free-ride on the
other's motors effort to get there which
means basically they're maximizing a
common
function minus some private cost which
could be their battery or something like
that yeah um
would that
increase the complexity
um too much to apply this methodology or
do you think there is all going in that
direction basically i'm thinking about
moral odds are kind of i think this is
very relevant i think there
i don't think it's out of the scope
we're studying actually this kind of
type of things
um
yeah i think it's very relevant and i
think it's possible i don't think this
is out of scope at all
exactly yes something that is complex in
the control in the accumulated control
right i mean if it's something simple
like you just subtract some cost for
each individual agent it's like convex
in the global right in the global
function so this will apply naturally
but there are other considerations when
you go to
economics like truthfulness or whatever
there are other strategic behavior you
know all these kind of things that are
more complicated but still i think this
is a great these are great questions
great directions to take this whole
thing
nice
uh okay maybe i'll ask one last question
um
yeah so i guess like part of the
motivation for doing you know these like
linear control problems especially with
the adversarial disturbances right it's
like you imagine maybe you have like a
non-linear system and you're like
linearizing this like maybe you want to
stabilize this right right have you
thought about at all whether there are
any settings where you can kind of get
like
provable guarantees for non-linear
systems by using this stuff as a
component yeah yeah edgar has some
upcoming thing about it yeah okay we
should talk to him yeah i mean it's good
yeah definitely um
and it relates to this direction of
applying adaptive regrets to these um
because you you need your adaptive
regret to behave better and how quickly
the system is changing yeah yeah so
actually i'll be happy to talk to you
okay cool that sounds sounds neat good
all right awesome yeah cool uh why don't
we stop there and we'll take a break uh
but we'll be starting back again at uh i
believe 11 30. yeah
and uh well actually let's let's give a
lot one more round of applause before we
go
[Applause]
yeah just